um I just I made the mistake of checking
to
before starting and I
retreat saying top conference tip don't
use the first person in in your talk
instead of saying I will teach say you
will learn etc I've already violated
that and I just done it again and again
and I'm afraid I'm probably going to
keep doing it this is in some ways quite
a personal Fork and the good thing is if
I keep saying I then it means you don't
have to feel any association with the
codes that you're going to see which may
be for the best um if you don't me don't
know me I'm John skeet I work for Google
I've worked there for about eight and a
half years for the last year and a half
I've been working on the C sharp support
for Google cloud platform it's awesome
go check out our booth um I've also been
abusing c-sharp for a long long time I
used to do this because I wasn't writing
any production c-sharp so it was fine to
write awful awful codes that was kind of
fun knowing it would never end up on a
production server now I need to be
slightly more careful that what I write
will you that I separate the abuse part
from the regular code the idea is to
look at interesting bits of the c-sharp
language which are right for being
misused and misuse them ideally in a way
that isn't just well this is crazy code
no one would ever want to do this but
here what that actually looks quite
appealing but no no no definitely not um
I would like this to be a collaborative
effort so in particular you know
Kathleen knows the language at least as
well as I do and I'm sure some of you do
as well so if you suddenly spot other
ways that we could abuse stuff you're
related to what I'm doing do shelf out
likewise if you're just come up on Sage
and start typing um I've done it to
other people no reason people shouldn't
do it to me likewise if you don't
understand what's going on then it's
possible you may actually learn
something in this session and there are
at least a couple of bits of code that
might be considered a bad idea or might
be considered a good idea and I might
ask for a show of hands but at least you
need to think carefully before using but
they really are appealing there are some
more chairs
around on this slide by the way so folks
are standing it doesn't bother me if you
walk in front of me it's fine okay
all the code is up on github I have a
blog that's almost entirely about code I
have a non code blog that's currently
almost entirely about feminism and we
have I have learnt that this talk is
better if I work out what I'm going to
teach you or show you beforehand out of
interest this is called abusing c-sharp
more because I've done abusing c-sharp
as a talk with some of the older stuff
several times how many of you have
already seen an abusing c-sharp talk by
me okay not very many so I might revisit
some of the most fun bits of that just
for a laugh and if not there's far far
more code than I could possibly go over
so it's really sort of picking some some
things we're going to start with the
Mongolian vowel separator which is my
favorite unicode character how many of
you were bill whiteners talk about
language design yesterday a few we
talked a little bit about breaking
changes and things that the language
specification refers to and I mentioned
Unicode and Bill was saying well that
doesn't change much allow me to differ
so we have a bit of code here most of
this code I will show you some code
we'll run it and see what it does
basically so what do you think this code
is going to do
sorry you know what I missed something
sorry they were I do want to call yeah
it's annoying I got a different version
that had the Schofield call but not the
assignment right okay so now more
usefully so I've got a little framework
that is just going to call me it's going
to do the obvious thing a thoughts it's
going to write in main okay I will prove
that you're actually correct and then
I'll show you why you might not have
been yes it prints in main if I have run
this and someday I would love to try to
find a version of Visual Studio 2010 but
with a rose in preview running on
running on a version of Windows from
about 2010 and because then I think it
would print in initializer and those of
you who are very close to the front how
many of you can read the line column and
character saying on the on the status
bar how many of you can see okay
enough to see the numbers so normally
focus on the coal and chair as I just
scroll around so if I go to the left
right as I go I'm pressing pressing
pressing pressing so I had to press
twice to go from the G to the X and
that's because the thing in the middle
there is the Mongolian valve separator
it doesn't exist here this just goes 28
28 29 29 30 30
no it's all it's all that so we have a
different sequence of Unicode characters
here and here but that's okay because
the language specification says that if
there are any Unicode formatting
characters within an identifier that's
fine and they'll sort of be normalized
the way in fact it doesn't say that
you'll normalize them ill say when you
compare when you try to find an
identifier ignore them and in fact the
way that the obvious way to do that is
just by normalizing them away and so if
you ask by reflection for string
you will get the version without without
the Mongolian valve separator so why
does this mean in 2010 it would have
printed something differently any
Unicode excuse me and trivia fans out
there well let me show you the history
of the Mongolian valve separator it was
introduced in Unicode 3.0 where it was
introduced as a formatting character and
then in 4.0 it became a whitespace
character and it's played a whitespace
character until 2014 so if we've been
running on something Unicode using
Unicode 6 it would be whitespace now
let's just replace the Unicode that the
mongolian vel separator with a regular
white space now that's still valid code
but it's going to print in initializer
yeah so as fine I don't know of any
other characters that have gone from one
Unicode category to another and then
back again and particularly to stay
valid in identifies but mean different
things or rather either separate
identifies all or be part of one so you
might be wondering what the
specification itself itself says and for
every published version of the c-sharp
specification it's gone too it's
specified that it uses Unicode 3 and the
the old CF feed Aleksey the native one
used to carry alongside it within it a
copy of Unicode 3x ma there's an ECMO
standard for c-sharp the third edition
covers c-sharp to the fourth edition
will cover c-sharp 5 when hopefully we
get that out this this half I really
really hope and then the idea is that we
can between ECMO and Microsoft we can
get the C sharp 6 specification and
standard out as sort of one thing so
you'll have seen that there isn't a
c-sharp
six spec publicly available other than a
draft version in a github repository
belonging to Lucian Bishop who's no
longer even in Microsoft but so ACMA
said it has before so if you tell the
c-sharp compiler to run in ISO so ECMO
is one standards body ISO is a different
standards body but the ACMA standard was
then fast-tracked to the ISO standard so
ISO to is equivalent to ECMO third
edition is somewhat equivalent to C
sharp to and I think this is still
what's he going to print if I can
actually run the thing come on
controller five so builders oh okay yeah
half of the rest of the code in the
project doesn't work under c-sharp -
let's see if i pull up
come on prompt I can write it the nice
thing about compiling the code with main
methods like this is I can compile just
a single file so it's in odds and ends
and they all remember the command line
that you use the specifies of the line
version so if I do line version ISO -
I'm gonna involve separator so it showed
in main still basically this shows that
the the compiler is not really obeying
the language choice that we've said
because that should mean use Unicode for
as of Rawson rather than just uses
whatever version of Unicode Ness is
using because that's the only thing that
really makes sense to keep going with so
in the fifth version of the unicode spec
sorry the fourth edition which is C
sharp 5 the upcoming one we're just
waving our hands
kind of saying it uses a version of
Unicode and let's hope it doesn't matter
let's stick with strings a bit more and
tighten it use name of so I'm going to
add a class notion of added before so
name of intro how many of you are using
C sharp 6 good and you're you're aware
of name of hopefully and I'll just
rename into to intro which is what I
meant so the next thing is if you come
into that ever so common scenario where
your Shift key is broken or possibly
you're working on a keyboard which is in
a different language and you don't know
where the double quotes are so you're
unable to type of string literal and
this is a problem we often monstering
literals and suppose you're in a
slightly better situation that vo the
string literals that you want to write
doesn't contain any spaces you've got
problems well you can use name of to
help you so you could declare a method
so suppose we want to print hello world
all is from one word okay we can do
console dot write line name of hello
world okay so without typing any double
quotes we can now run that and it will
print hello world but you know that kind
of sucks because you've got to introduce
a whole extra method and that's not fun
and you could have you could do a
variable called hello world instead and
then it's still just a bit nasty and
then you think of dynamic so one of the
things you can do with name of is refer
to instance or static methods members
via a reference so normally if I do
string x equals whatever even know and I
can't type X dots
give me a static method on string is
null or empty
I can't use X dot is null or empty
because it's a static method and c-sharp
made the very good decision unlike Java
that you shouldn't be able to call
static methods on variables on any kind
of reference as if it's an instance
method what I can do is refer to the
static method via an instance I think no
it's the other way around you can refer
to an instance yes sorry you can refer
to an instance method and I can do
exports plate
I hope no it's because I'm lame old si I
hope that you would be on your toes yeah
and that now works good whew right so
even though is null or empty you can't
call as X dot is no empty you can use X
dot to just say what type we're
interested in great so now that means I
can write hello world without ever
introducing anything in my program text
that says hello world introducing any
kind of members because this syntax also
works for dynamic so we can write
dynamically is null and then do name of
d dot hello world or d mongolian Val
separator and as you can imagine D
Mongolian Val separator has the
Mongolian Val separator between the N
and the V and then between the Ellender
capital S so between the words and as a
bonus feature not only is it allowing us
to write that text but it will also do
unicode normalization for us so this is
exactly the same on copy copy pasting
into here so you might expect that that
length and that length will be the same
but actually the length property on
string is going to include the mongolian
val separator whereas the version here
is not going to be the same string
because it doesn't include it it's been
normalized away and we can see that if
we do name of anything
see that we get Mongolian valve
separator we have a length of 23 without
the mbss and 25 width so next time
you're faced with a broken keyboard or
you know if if kathleen's up here and
trying to find the double quotes you no
longer need to worry about it just use
name of on dynamic see always useful
stuff okay yeah and just those next
caffeine she doesn't have anything like
fruit or anything with heard she just
okay hmm
I may need duck Kathleen yesterday we're
saying about when not to use topple
deconstruction well how about for dates
and times
how would you deconstruct a date so this
is C sharp 7 feature you can write VAR
XYZ equals foo if who has a deconstruct
method with 3 out parameters and the
trouble with States is you know we like
to think of it as day month year and
Kathleen probably like to think of it as
months a year and we should really you
know be open and inclusive of everyone
so really what we want to be able to
deconstruct using date time extensions
and you have x y&z and who knows what x
y&z will be maybe they will be year
months they may be there will be months
a year maybe there will be day month
year so if we run this and run it the
first time it's doing day month year
which is you know reasonably sensed it
and it's sensible if I do hash define us
date format
sorry it was it was months a year then
presumably and actually I don't define
it there I define it in the extensions
so I can define
and it needs to be above the using
directives again I can define that we
want the ISO date format which is kind
of useful instead of the u.s. date
format so I can do us explicitly 119 and
if I do UK date format then I don't need
to change my calling code at all I can
put this one place in the project and it
will now do 19 1 2017 and that's just
simple preprocessor thing but what I do
like about this is that I haven't
changed my implementation at all my
deconstruct method I've just changed the
signature to have day month year or
months a year or year month day and then
the body of the method in every case
uses the same thing well ok that's
that's fine if you're happy to set the
project do this define not here but in
the project properties but what if in
some source files you some of your
fourth is written by UK developers and
some of its written by us developers and
they both want to be able to not write
you wouldn't actually write that you
would write whatever comes naturally to
you so I bright day month year in fact I
write year month day because I'm so used
to the ISO format and then in a
different file Cassidy might want to
write month day year well we've got her
covered too because instead of having
one implementation we can have three
different implementations all still
extension methods just in different
classes and so long as we use using
static and say which one we want to
import we'll get the right thing so if
we this will do the ISO date format so
we'll end up with 2017 119 yes and then
yes if scattering were writing some code
instead we could use this and she would
then declare var months a year and it
would all do the right thing so this
allows you to let developers from
multiple cultures write perfectly nice
code for themselves
so long as only people from the same
culture ever need to read or maintain
that code then everyone's happy
don't do any of this if I didn't make it
really clear before don't do any of it
however I do really like I would
recommend the using static as a way of
importing extension methods we have this
in no time I have a testing assembly
which has a bunch of extension methods
on int and double and things so that you
can do this won't work here but I'd be
able to do local date birthday equals 19
June 1976 which I wouldn't recommend in
production code but it's really clear
when you're writing test code for you
know maybe you've got some analysts or
whatever has said suppose the year
starts here the business year starts on
April the 1st well 1.8 Perl 2015 is
really really clear and and I've got
different ones for local dates or you
know another time I could write duration
session length equals 1 dot hours for
example but I don't necessarily want
both the hours extension method and the
June extension method at the same time
and before c-sharp 7 so it before
c-sharp 6 this is a problem because you
imported the whole of all of the
extension methods within one namespace
in one go just with using stuff now you
can pick I want the extension methods
from that class please and that class
but not the one in the middle this is
one of my beefs that I've been giving
feedback to Microsoft on since 2005 and
as of 2015 it's all good ok do shell if
there's anything in the meantime that
you want to come up with otherwise I'll
just keep moving on to the next thing so
how many of you like regions hash region
stuff yeah ok um I used to like it more
than I do now I sometimes use it if if
I've got a huge amount of code that's
sort of all boilerplate stuff that's
quite handy but I don't use it
religiously all the time um the trouble
is it looks a bit boring but the great
thing is with expression body members we
can get something that looks a little
bit like that but a bit more attractive
just by declaring a property or a field
well a property so ignore the the
implementation details for now but look
how we can write something that's a
little bit like a region okay it's not
going to fold but isn't that nice we can
highlight it as much as we like we could
you know get rid of the middle bit so
long as we've got some balance actually
I'm not even sure that balance is
required but we can you know have a bit
awesome code you could use this for
different levels of headings it's great
and the the name Jay here I couldn't
find anything any Unicode identifier
that looks like a backward semicolon and
we do need to have the semicolon so if
anyone finds any Unicode characters that
are valid in identifiers and I could use
as the variable name that would be
awesome but so this is a property of
type J call underscore which is a get
only property that returns a well it's
got to return a J and J is a delegate
that itself returns a J when given a
middle bit as the sort of fairly self
descriptive stuff that comes in the
middle so we've got a lambda expression
that itself returns a lambda expression
which returns all we've got some strings
here well we've got to have been given
this this will have to be middle bit in
order to get the lambda expression for J
to work so if this is a middle bit we
want to return a J given a less than or
equal between a string and the middle
bit well okay less than or equal between
string and middle bit we can do here
we've got operator overloading but then
we also need to be able to convert from
a middle bits to J and that's fine we
can just do an implicit conversion and
all of these do null is not actually
going to do anything and I can't
remember offhand
oh yes the reason I need the implicit
conversion from a J to a little bit is
well
that's going to be a middle bit but then
I need to compare that with another
middle bit
it's possible that I could get away with
less than or equal between J and middle
bit as well but an implicit conversion
is simpler the one you know the one
thing that you might want to complain
about this code and obviously the only
thing is that we have to include these
greater than or equal to operators as
well and that's just the compiler won't
let you do less than or equal to but not
greater than or equal to so you know
maybe that's the one thing that makes
you decide not to use this code who can
help okay preprocessor oddities this is
a slightly old one and this is not new
to c-sharp at all but it's just an
interesting thing around the fact that
c-sharp doesn't really have a
preprocessor so if you give the seed
pre-process or something it sort of
doesn't really care about the code it
just cares about your hash defines and
your hash if etc etc c-sharp is a little
bit different so you can confuse things
I wouldn't ask what you think this will
show because actually Visual Studio is
highlighting it already but here we have
we're defining foo up at the top and
then we're saying if foo and so we're
printing out so is defined and then we
start a multi-line comment and this is
the interesting bit the hash elf I
believe in a C preprocessor and someone
will say I'm wrong I believe in the C
preprocessor that hash else would say oh
no well who was defined so I'll ignore
everything from here onwards the c-sharp
compiler is saying no you're in a
multi-line comment so the piles are
really LexA you're in a multi-line
comment so that hash else is just part
of the multi-line comment that's
absolutely fine so we'll keep going and
this is all part of the comments and the
comment ends with this with this star
slash and at that point we're out to the
comment so this elf means the
preprocessor is saying oh I'll just
nor everything else fine so we just
print foo is defined if we don't define
so let's define foo - instead suddenly
okay we don't see this and we don't see
the start of the comment you can write
whatever you like
in stuff that's ignored by the
preprocessor so it doesn't care about
the start of a comment so it sees this
elf as the bit that it should start
caring about and now we print foo is not
defined and now this little bit here
that the second half of this was the end
comment when foo is defined
it's now the beginning of a multi-line
comment because sue isn't defined so now
we're in a multi-line comment again and
this hash elf that was useful before is
now in a comment and we just have this
comment and we end it I suspect I
suspect I could probably take that away
and the whole thing would keep working
either way but it's kind of multi metric
as it is so this will print so is not
defying twice can anyone think of a
similar feature we could use to
demonstrate something kind of the same
although it'll have a little bit more
effect on the output what else might
start consuming that hash elf not as a
preprocessor hash elf Oh sort of
elaborate so if I leave off the end here
it's just going to say well that's
certain unterminated string literal
multi-line strings yes for rating string
literals so this is largely similar here
we have foo is defined so we're going to
get a verbatim string literal that's the
app there which says foo is defined and
then the string contains hash else and
it also contains string X equal F and
then this double quote here is the end
of the verbatim string literal
so this will print so is define elf
string equal that if we don't define foo
or defined through two now this isn't
the end of the previous string literal
it's the start of a new verbatim string
literal and now this else is consumed
and now we've got through is not defined
and this is one of those things that no
it doesn't actually have any I can't
pretend it could be useful in any way
shape or form but it is quite fun I'll
give another one of those that I have
presented before so feedback welcome
something I wasn't aware you could do
before which was to use attributes on
flight parameters has anyone ever seen
and this is actually a use that maybe
with a rosin analyzer which you know is
to do you could have so sue is a generic
type and it's type parameter the type
parameter itself has an attribute of
must be immutable and you can imagine
writing a roles and analyzer saying
everywhere I see a foo of tea or a foo
or something
I will validate that either that's a foo
of tea in a generic method or type where
the tea also has must be immutable or if
it's a concrete type argument I'll check
that it has the immutable attribute so
here in in our usage code we've got bar
is a class which is immutable Baz is a
class which isn't and we would like this
to be fine and that's not to be fine and
sure we can't change the actual compiler
rules to say c-sharp says it's wrong but
we could fairly easily I well fairly
easily and writing rosin analyzers is
not easy but it's feasible and I I think
it would be entirely feasible to write
analyzer so that it would come up with
an error here and that could be actually
useful but I'm intrigued has anyone else
seen the bit of syntax to be clear this
is the syntax that is surprising to me
anyone see you have right
what was it useful
ah right in core effects labs it's used
for is primitive and so it could check
endianness is that Alright okay so it
could cope with networked house order or
host the network order depending on the
native Indian Asst cool if anyone sees
any any uses in the wild beyond that
please email me cuz I would love to
collect them somewhere you could right
so yes you could do it for enums or
delegates instead for unconstrained
melody type things yes yeah that would
be quite a cool thing and intellisense
won't help you there but yeah yeah yeah
that'd be a nice way of doing things
cool let me know if you find anything
else let me just shut some windows down
I think we're dealing with string
interpolation next yes we are right so
you'll use string interpolation in
c-sharp six are you all aware that it
uses the current culture by default so
if you're logging using variant culture
I'll come back to logging so lambda
expressions the expression in an
interpolated string literal has to be an
expression okay so you can't do this
this is meant to be
well I'm opening the bit that's meant to
be the interpolated part and then oh
I'll just have a block here and do stuff
in the block now that's not allowed
that's not an expression lambda
expressions are expressions but they
don't have a type so you can't just
write you know I can do lambda
so I can't do console dot write line and
then just goes through why yeah won't
work okay that's not going to pass
because the lambda expression has no
type so it can't convert it to anything
but you can cast the lambda expression
to a delegate flight and then you can
just use it on its own so if I let me
just comment everything else out here
the hideousness we'll see later
so if we just have a longer expression
thank you okay so this now compiles I
believe and we've got the lambda
expression we've got that in brackets
because precedence and then we've got a
cast I suppose I could do it probably Jo
I don't think I've ever tried to get
away from casting by just using as it's
not going to work now I think I think
you'd still need the brackets and even
then okay as operator isn't as powerful
as cough fine bum bum right okay so this
is now converting it to a func of string
and this is just going to print or am I
on I'm on the wrong project straight
interpolation on lambda expression okay
so that's just printing oh it's a func
of strings well once we've got a func of
string we know how to invoke it so we
can just add a couple of brackets we can
let's make it a little bit more readable
by calling in poke instead and so now
when we evaluate the string
as in when at the execution time it
evaluates this argument it will create
the delegates and then immediately
invoke it which will print hello and
then return why great we can then if we
want to avoid the cast if you know
you're doing this regularly in code for
some bizarre reason and you can just
write a method and in this case I have
got it in the same class but you could
write it somewhere else and import
static there using static it so that you
could use it everywhere and then you
just need to pass in the lambda
expression that will do exactly the same
thing but you can if you can stomach the
brackets you can do a whole program in
our interpolated string literal so when
we run this well let's just run it and
then have a look at the code so ah
what's your name
John hello John so the order of
execution here is it we have console dot
write line starting with hello but
before we can get into the console dot
write line evaluation sorry
invocation we have to evaluate this
string and this string which is a
verbatim interpolate sorry interpolated
verbatim string literal is going to need
to create this delegate and then invoke
it and the delegate will print something
else to the console then ask our name
and then we're returning the name so
that that can be appended on to hello
and that's what ends up being called to
console lot right line so I think you
can see this can radically simplify your
code yeah
Oh yep Oh crikey I will let's noodle on
that later on I think we can definitely
come up with something nastier yeah
but yes I think trying to do that now is
going to fail but there are other things
we can do with string interpolation
which are fun so normally with regular
string interpolation even if we use
formattable string and this is the bit
that you might learn something more how
many of you have used the theme for
Mashable string okay right brief
diversion so the type of an interpolated
string literal is string formattable
string is a type introduced in net 4.6
and next standard one three
there is no conversion from string the
type to formattable string but there is
an implicit conversion from an
interpolated string literal expression
to formattable string if that sounds
crazy
it isn't you've seen this before if I do
var X equal ten the type of X is int the
type of the integer literal there is int
I cannot do bite y equals x that won't
compile because there's no implicit
conversion from int to bite but I can do
bite y equals 10 because there is an
implicit conversion from a constant
expression of an integer type where the
constant value is within the range of
bite to bite okay
so it's worth getting in your head that
the difference between a conversion for
a type to another type or a conversion
from an expression to another types and
you also get that with lambda
expressions they have no type so there
has to be an implicit conversion from a
lambda expression to some other type or
you could
use them but it is a slightly subtle
difference and dynamic has conversions
one way but not the other it's really
desert so the point of formattable
string though the real usage of
formattable strings is to be able to
perform the string formatting in
whatever culture you want
that's the intended use so obviously
we're not going to bother doing that
we'll do more interesting stuff instead
when you use a conversion from a string
and interpolate string literal to form a
full string it works out what it would
do in terms of what's the format string
that it's going to call string dot
format with so that ends up being that
here's a regular braces with numbers in
and it evaluates value in this case and
it does that once and create an instance
of formattable string that's got the
format string and the arguments as
values so that's evaluated once and then
when you call format small dots of
string it says ok I will call string dot
format
yeah with whatever culture you specify
if you're specifying one and pass in the
values that I evaluated before and it
does that evaluation once in the
conversion so here unlike for example
with link where if you have a link query
imagine something like this but as a
link query changing value if value were
captured within your link crew changing
the value of value would change the
results of the query here if I run this
regular evaluation it's going to print
before twice and then the bit of code
that's counting here well our
formattable string is just Oh get date
time net at UTC now that's evaluated
once and then retained wouldn't it be
nice if we could evaluate things kind of
lazily instead at the points of
formatting instead of at the point of
constructing the formattable string well
we can sort of with a bit of work so
this is very similar code to what you
saw
before except for this chunk okay
so fairly obviously this is a lambda
expression and we have a method that
accepts a thunk of object and returns
whatever I call it captured capture so
it remembers not well it is evaluating
it once and it evaluates to a single
delegate but the good thing is we've now
got a delegate and we can invoke that
delegate as many times as we like and in
particular we can implement I
formattable which means that when string
dot format gets called will end up in
here and at that point we can then just
pull our delegate so we can evaluate it
every time we're formatted we can
re-evaluate the delegate and if we've
been given if it returns a value which
is also formattable then we can pass on
the format string to that so for example
in this date time now I specified that I
just want to give the hour minute second
and down to millisecond so if we run
this code instead even though just to be
really clear all we're doing is printing
formattable ten times every time we
print it there we go
it's printing a different time
let's take a formattable string one step
further how many of you know about
sequel injection attacks anyone who
didn't put their hand up the first thing
they do after this session all you're
allowed to leave now is you right up
there you go and read and OB tables calm
or just search for sequel injection
attacks and never ever write sequel that
looks like this okay let's get rid of
that for the moment but none of you
sorry none of you would ever write code
like that right it's clearly going to be
broken well you know you might think
that you need apostrophes around the
name ideas and integers so that's fine
but that's clearly going to break if if
name has any apostrophes in this is the
one that I'm saying you can use this if
you want it is justifiably nice and but
there are some downsides to think about
but they're not sequel injection with
this code so I assert that this is safe
code we're not calling new sequel
command we're calling new sequel command
so we're not calling the sequel command
constructor we're calling this extension
method that I've created on sequel
connection so far so good
and that doesn't accept a string it
accepts a formattable string but the
interesting thing is what it does with
that formattable string I'm going to
sort of ruin the surprise and show you
the results now so and when we run it
I'm not going to talk to a natural
database of course and instead I'm going
to print the command text and then there
are two parameters and I'll print their
names and their values so parameter or a
sequel okay does that look much more
like something that you want to evaluate
yeah if you're not using entity
framework or whatever yes
that's now a perfectly reasonable way of
doing the query and the good news is you
didn't have to write command dot
parameters dot add p0 and make sure p0
was the same as you put in the secret
itself you never put p0 anywhere in your
code how many people are interested in
the token p0 and want that to appear in
their source code no one no it's it's
just an artifact of I want to link this
bit here to this parameter over here so
in order to do this now you've seen the
results how do we do it so we have our
new sequel command method that takes a
formattable string there are two bits in
formattable string there's the format
which live carefully document it will be
this and sorry I didn't put the ml jar
back in up here ok so yep as the format
and then you can go get arguments which
will return you an object array with the
arguments in which in our case are going
to be the name and the ID great
so first bit is pretty simple we can
take the Vettes take the arguments and
convert just the arguments into sequel
parameters wrapping those arguments and
we'll use the overload of selects that
accepts the position as well and we'll
use that to name our parameters so we
end up with p0 p1 p2 etc and we can
specify the value there as well that
leaves two things we need to get the
sequel itself correct and we need to
handle types so that you can specify
what you want the sequel DB type to be
well both of these are done with format
capturing parameter so we're taking our
sequel parameters so we've got p0 corey
p110 and wrapping each of those in a
format capturing parameter so it's a
parameter that captures formats and then
all we're doing then is using those as
the actual arguments for string format
so that clearly the interesting bit is
going to be what happens when you format
one of these format capturing parameters
so format capturing parameter in turn
remembers the sequel parameter it's
wrapping and then it does two things
when the string is called the first is
so that we get the command text right
it's just returning the name of the
parameter so where we have the
placeholder in the original interpolated
string literal that's where we want the
@p 0 yes great so that's what the final
bit of code is but also as a side effect
and you never ever ever make formatting
a string have side effects but in this
case it's kind of useful so we're going
to see whether we've got a bit to the
right of the colon that says how to
format the value and we're saying that
if you like the format of the first
parameter is that it's an inverter so
all we need to use is oenomaus and we'll
say oh we don't care about casing so we
could do int here and this will use M or
let's use text instead I think and now
if we run this again instead of saying M
bar chart it will save the type is text
is come up with sequel DV type text so
out of interest I'll give you the
downsides now so the upside is this
looks cleaner ignore the diagnostic
stuff this is all you need to do to end
up with a sequel command that has all
the parameters and you can see where the
parameters are you won't get any of
those cases where you've added the same
parameter with two different names or
you know you need to look back from the
sequel to the parameter filling code
you've got them all in the right place
that's the good bit the bad bit is you
hire a new developer who may be new to
c-sharp they see this and they think
that's the way that I'll do
all new sequel command connection that
and suddenly bang sequel injection
attack or likewise you have you run some
static tool analysis that says that
looks awfully like a sequel string that
you're using string interpolation for
I'm going to complain at you so if
you're not using the static tools and
you're quite capable of explaining to
every member of your team how this works
I think this could be a win how many
people do like this a few and how many
really don't a smaller number really
don't okay and the rest of you are sort
of not entirely sure did everyone follow
the explanation you should never ever
use this code if you don't understand it
okay definitely
but this is you know potentially useful
code I see I've only got ten minutes
left
I've gone through about maybe 15% of the
code within this solution so go and have
a look on github later let me see what
we'll do are any of the rest really
really fun compared with now let's do
some link everyone like link yeah and I
like link as well but the one thing I
don't like about it is it's so verbose
you have to write so much code to do
anything you know take select for
instance that's six characters I'm never
going to get back from my life so I
think we've got other ways that we can
write link queries we just need to you
know write the framework for them so
that's there's an intro somewhere basic
demo so I was looking at some operators
I've got the evil method I might rename
that to to link to operators at some
point so it just takes any ienumerable
and then lets us work with link to
operators so here we have you know
ampersand it's a bit like bitwise
operands it's a bitwise evaluation it's
always going to shrink things so it's
very much like a filter that's going to
do our where for us and then we think of
link as a pipeline year we massage
the shape of the pipe changes so the
pipe operator is going to be our select
so let's just look through what this is
going to do so we start off with hello
world how are you so I get a little tip
and then we'll take away from that
sequence the world so clearly that
leaves hello how are you
and then we'll concatenate today notice
how already this is so much simpler than
it would have been in them linked to
object yeah
then we'll filter it yeah you may not be
terribly used to seeing lambda
expressions as operands but hey it works
you do need the brackets I think it
won't compile them precedents again gets
completely confused and so will convert
it will filter out anything that's
shorter than five characters so end up
with hello how are you
sorry hello today and then we'll convert
each of those to uppercase and I'm no
longer thinking about culture and flows
and whatever so I don't care that it
uses account culture so I will print
that query three times yeah why not
multiply a sequence by a number that's
clearly just going to be hello today
hello today hello today and the other
example in this basic demo is XOR so XOR
for two sequences is fairly obvious and
it's just going to be things that are in
one sequence or the other sequence but
not both so this should print through
bars crux so we should end up with hello
today hello today hello today food as
quacks basically alright so that's some
of the operators and I will go into a
couple of my favorites in a minute but
do any of you have favorite operators
dear me no favorite unicode character no
favorite operator yeah I try to adopt
the Mongolian Bell separator because
they're they're running a scheme where
you can pay 50 bucks or something to
adopt character they don't let you adopt
formatting characters it's most sad one
day the Mongolian Bell separator will
have a certificate on my wall so I've
overloaded everything you can overload
as I'll see sharp six
I haven't yet tried to overload the is
operator which I didn't know about some
tell Kathleen tells me about it
yesterday see or visit built it was even
alright yeah so there's still got to go
but I've overloaded everything else
let's have a look at division and before
I switch to the code when it might be a
bit a little bit more obvious what do
you think it means to divide a sequence
by something sorry
difference between them well that's more
subtract is a different thing you could
do with subtraction split okay what kind
of split are we talking about give us an
example right okay so take a collection
of length 6 and divide it by 3 and you
get collections each with either each
with 3 or dividing it into three
collections that's one way of doing it
and and that's one thing I've
implemented so that's the second part
here where if we divide our sequence of
each of the words I'm splitting at the
end of this very long line and I'm
calling split so we've got a bunch of
words from Hamlet and then we're
dividing them by 5 and I've chosen to
make that mean divide them into groups
of sequences of 5 and that nicely means
that the remainder operator is clearly
you know we won't give you a batch of
less than 5 words and the remainder
operator will give you whatever was left
over after that division great and I'm
more fond of dividing by a function so
let's start off with our little company
where people are in different
departments and if I said to someone
non-techie at all here's a bunch of
people in the company could you divide
them by Department they would naturally
group them into you know well all the
people from accounting over here all the
people from sales over here so we can do
exactly that so we can take the
employees and divide them by a lambda
expression that shows the department
I'll just show you that division so too
much stuff so we've got accounting has
days sales has Bill and Betty etc and
our dividing by an integer and the
double commas here where there was a
comma in the original text so we've got
five words here to be or not to then be
that is the question whether tis nobler
in the etcetera and I think Shakespeare
would be a lot duller if you read it
always in sections of five words it
wouldn't quite have the same thing and
I'll show you my other favorite this is
the the operator dedicated to Eric
Lippert Eric made a foolish statement
one time he said that the unary plus
operator is kind of pointless it's only
there for symmetry
what other use could it possibly have
it's there so that you can write plus
five you know VAR x equals plus five and
that still work because that's symmetric
with minus five I say there are
interesting other things you can do with
it before I guess on to unary plus
though what about unary minus what does
it mean if I have a sequence
what does - sequence mean just on its
own not through - sequence just you know
var new sequence equals - sequence what
would you like it to do reversing
someone said reversing okay anything
else it could do lower case okay I
haven't implemented that but I'll hear
that as the equivalent of sort of
negating element-wise which is if if you
view negating a capital letter to a
lowercase letter if you start with
numbers instead you could have negative
numbers when I asked on Twitter someone
else suggested it could pop the sequence
so the return value could be the first
element of the sequence but in
evaluating it
you could also modify the sequence that
you call this on and remove that first
element again
ever ever do that operators should not
modify anything and however we can
there's nothing to stop us from doing it
so let's do it and I should show you the
some of the code for this by the way is
in operator enumerable it's mostly very
simple so you know if we have plus we
can use all our normal operators there
are all the normal linked operators and
I have everything's kind of dynamic but
the implementation is a lot less sort of
fun because it's fairly trivial it's a
lot less fun than the things you do with
it so we have three different things we
could do with the unary minus operator
and this is where the unary plus
operator comes in I've implemented the
unary plus operator as a sort of mode
selector so if you just do - sequence
I believe it reverses it yes so -
sequence is the reversal sequence but
then if we use plus sequence to mean the
same sequence just with a different
meaning for unary - so it goes on and it
goes it cycles round so you can go from
reverse to negate each individual item -
popping mode which is the previous mode
so if we print - sequence here we'll get
the reverse so these first seven digits
of pi so reverse will get to nine five
one four one three if we do - plus
sequence we'll end up with just minus
three minus one minus four minus one
minus 5 minus nine minus two and of
course we can and combine these so -
sequence we've seen is the reverse one
starting with two plus - sequence is the
reverse one starting with two but in a
different mode and - + - sequence is the
reverse time negated so it's minus 2 - 9
- 5 etc if we want to get into popping
mode the plus + operator is clearly
entirely different from + + that I can't
remember what it does but it's it's
bound to do something different
so we have to have this this annoying
space in there of course it's the
Mongolian vowel separator was still
being deemed a space I could put that in
there so you would find it hard to tell
the difference between that and plus
plus Oh for those halcyon days and then
if we print popping three times we end
up with 3 then one then four and then if
we print just popping instead of -
popping sorry and it will print 1 5 9 -
and then just to prove that it does
indeed cycle if we do plus plus plus
sequence and then negate the result will
go back to just reversing so let's run
that yeah where where that result is the
same as the straight reversing and as I
say I've got all the other operators
there so the tilde operator looks like a
bit of a wavy line to me who knows
exactly what it's going to do so it
shuffles the elements it just shuffles
the sequence there are other things
powers and all kinds of stuff please go
and investigate on github and unless
I've completely misread my timing I'm
now out of time come and see me for any
questions about details have a look on
github I haven't written explanation for
any of it but hopefully you can get a
feeling of it and and I hope you've
enjoyed it don't use any of it thank you
[Applause]